hypergamy so I'm just curious for the
ladies on the panel have you guys heard
of hypergamy
yes yes I have now yeah
I'm keep watching for today not before
today I Googled it just for coming home
okay so hypergamy is the action of
marrying or forming a sexual
relationship with a person of a superior
sociological or educational background
so the idea is that when women date we
want to date up in some way whether it's
they make more money than us they're
more educated than us or they're better
looking than us and this is just when
you survey women on what they want in a
man and what researchers have come to
find out is that a hundred percent of
women want 20 percent of men
and so the reason a lot of times girls
say things like men are trash men are
the problem that sort of thing men
always cheat is because we're all dating
the same ones
and some people think it's even smaller
some people say five percent but I just
say 20 on like the high end
yeah and is that overall yeah well it's
the way they find this out is through
dating app data
so there's only available the women that
want to date up there's only 20 of yeah
available so I'll give you an example
um how many of you guys want to do a guy
over six foot
No 5 10. what's your height requirement
go ahead I don't think I have a hot
actually I don't want to date anyone
five five so okay that's that's five
eleven five eleven okay I'm barely five
one so okay you got the whole you got
the whole anything up here's a bonus I'm
five six so I tend to want somebody
around my height a lot taller okay yeah
I mean I'm a fellow shorty so I've never
really had to think about it so the
reason I bring this up is because most
girls when I ask them height wise they
want to date they're height or taller
and so that's just a an example of how
women use hypergamy so Mike yeah yeah
you see right interesting so my question
is
a common complaint that I hear from men
is that women have too high of Standards
when are standards too high and I want
to go around starting there
um
I don't agree with that statement okay
go ahead I just think
a lot a lot of Deeds are weak and so
instead of rising to the competition
they'll rather tell women hey man you
should just want less but from what I
see in the dating game the
characteristics or the qualities women
want on
are things you can develop you know some
of the best seduces in history maybe
Neil Strauss who wrote the game he's a
bold 40 year old man and he got the most
Tower of anyone in New York so the idea
that it's about being six foot in a
million as completely untrue and these
guys know this because they complain
about Chad and Tyrone and Chad and Tarot
is never like some rich guy as it you
know so um yeah but those qualities of
being kind being charismatic being
sophisticated in some way being athletic
you guys can hit the gym you can learn
how to talk to women you can be more
patient you know you could respect her
more in certain ways so I don't agree
that the standards are too high
okay go ahead
um the standard's too high I think I
think women have
a lot of expectations when it comes to
men and I think sometimes those
expectations aren't always realistic
um
I do think
that men obviously do think that women
um
think too highly of themselves sometimes
but I think that's the damn problem to
be fair I think they need to I think
they need to up their game in regards to
being a lot more understanding when it
comes to women and yeah that's just
that's my opinion okay go ahead
um yeah I'd say the same and women's
expectations more than standards and and
kind of lost the words no yeah
I don't think women's standards are too
high I agree more or less with
everything and you said that
do men have to kind of
come to an understanding of what men
have to be more I'd say anything more
I'd say women's expectations are more on
an emotional level than a money level up
for me anyway they were they weren't
like a guy that's emotionally available
is that yeah for me yes it's I'd rather
someone that was emotionally available
than someone that had a lot of money
okay what about you I kind of depends if
you're looking at the oh talk a little
closer it depends if you're looking at
the real world or through dating apps
because on dating apps it's easy to say
yeah I want X Y and Z but actually when
you meet people naturally you'll find
that a lot of that kind of goes out the
window and you're happy as long as you
just have that connection or the basic
fundamentals with that individual which
comes down to like the emotional
intelligence and things like that as
opposed to saying okay what's your
salary how tall are you what do you do
okay go ahead I would say that there's a
difference between being selective and
having high standards I think that women
and it's it's if you look at dating
updates or it's very well understood
that that women are
they will they will swipe less freely
they'll be they'll think more about
their swiping and they'll probably swipe
right less often whereas men if you're
going to stereotype we'll just you know
get they will play the numbers game
um but I wouldn't say because women are
looking for a man of a certain height
and a certain income I think they're
looking for someone who they click with
more and there just seems to be a
phenomenal and then seem to play their
numbers game more okay what do you think
I think a lot that was a lot to wrap him
all right firstly yeah
okay so all right the 80 of men that
we're talking about
you have to understand that they're
completely invisible
we're talking about ramroop from chicken
Cottage we're not you know what I'm
trying to say you look like so when when
we're starting we're starting at a basis
where you already are this is Tyrone
he's already six foot I already know
what he does you don't need to ask him
what his career is you already know he's
so I want someone that's nice is because
you want someone that's nice that
already has the fits the narrative the
person of what you want
you're not going to be attracted to
someone that you're not attracted to or
doesn't fit your criteria and women in
the west criteria is very high
and they all have to they all seem to
have the same criteria they all want the
same type of guy even though they would
love to admit that they don't want the
same type of guy maybe it doesn't work
out with the right type of guy and now
you move on to another guy that you you
don't feel as happy that you are with
that guy when really and truly you wish
that guy that you really want was like
the guy that you're with now is more
what happens when you say like out on
the road that you meet people no people
women have to settle and they do settle
when they hit the wall they settle when
they've been through too much stress
they settle when they need money the
problems they they settle when when they
when they like you know what this guy's
just on my case so much let me just all
right
that's when they settle but they're
really trying to get that main guy and
if that main guy came when they are in a
relationship with that the guy that they
settled
you know the guy okay I'll give you I'll
give you an example okay most girls that
I know
even there's one guy that they just like
really deeply loved right and they loved
more than all of their other exes and
they could be dating the next guy or the
next guy or the next guy but if that ex
calls they're back
I think that comes of age okay I think
um obviously I'm 40 one sorry I'm 41 and
um
I don't go back I go forward but if I
ever gone back in my young I've gone
back for sex
that's it
so I wouldn't ever look at that person
as to have a relationship with if I
haven't you know been seeing anyone and
I want to have sex then I might go back
to that person or I did go back to the
person in the past but yeah do you think
it's your choice
of course it's my choice
you think a man wanting to have a
relationship with you is your choice
yeah I do so what do you think will
separate the man that just wants to
sleep with you from the man that wants
to have a relationship with you
very good question
I don't know it's the individual thing
isn't it I mean
I can probably count on one hand the
amount of men who just wanted to sleep
with me
so
yeah every girl wants to sit with you
no but I mean I mean I mean we all know
that when when a man meets a woman it's
initially you know attraction isn't it
like
obviously women have the same thing as
well it's not it's not just Men by the
way no it's not the same
um well I can look at a man and think oh
I'd just love to sleep with him but he's
not I wouldn't really want to be with
him for the rest of my life so we do
have that as well yeah but do you get
attached when it happens I don't know
so do you think that's because you've
passed the stage where you can get
attached
no I've never been attached you've never
been attached through sex no never never
neither no
you've never been in a long-term
relationship
but it wasn't because of the sex and the
sex are you meaning has the sex kept us
there
man I'm saying I'm not saying wept I'm
saying you've never grown to love a man
through sex
ever
no I don't think I have I've Loved
someone's sex yeah
it's because someone is good in bed no
way I'm not saying you'll stay only
because he's good and bad but that's
typically how women Bond we release a
hormone during sex that men don't which
is oxytocin so basically like women fall
in love through orgasms I was like as
weird as weird as that is but like yeah
like because we release a hormone that
they don't but as somebody that so when
I think I've had a lot of long-term
relationships I'm like a relationship
person and I'll often wait for quite a
while before I have sex with the guy so
I want to date them first I want to get
to know what's about see if there's a
connection or anything like that and I
can also go through phases of not
sleeping with them because I think most
of the intimacy doesn't come through sex
it comes through spending time with that
person building a connection with that
person and making memories and things
I'm not I'm not saying that's the only
way you can bond with a guy I'm just
saying women Bond through sex in a way
that men don't I think and and you could
you can think it whatever but I'm saying
like so after study will tell you women
bond in a way that men don't maybe maybe
I'm talking to four exceptions I don't
know so is that is that what so men do
not Bond through sex we do they they do
but not in the same way they get they
really sell hormone that makes them
territorial that's why like
some guys you know they'll sleep with a
girl and they'll move on and they'll
still be mad when the next guy hits
because they released a whole